117 гривень за кілограм томатів й 114 - за огірок сорту "Естафета".
Такі ціни цієї весни можна було побачити в українських супермаркетах.
Згідно зі статистикою Мінфіну, у  середньому, ціни на фрукти й овочі зросли на 85% у порівнянні з минулою весною.
Ситуація на вуличних ринках також не сильно відрізняється.
На одному з київських ярмарків також відчувається здорожчання як ніколи раніше.
Продавці кажуть, що на деякі овочі ціни зросли ледь не на 50%.
Всі вказують, що основний фактор здорожчання овочів - це зростання цін на паливо.
Наталія Соломон їздить продавати овочі на київських ярмарках з Хмельницької області.
Частково жінка реалізує свою власну продукцію, частково - перепродає городину інших фермерів.
Наталія також скаржиться на високі ціни.
Якщо того року я продавала помідору 60-70 грн. кілограм, то дивіться зараз які помідори.
І огірок подорожчав, і помідора подорожчала. На минулий рік редиска дорога. Капуста дорога - у цю пору, щоб була така закупка…
Ну зелень... Насіння дороге, все, і все залежить від топлива. Пальне подорожчало і все, все подорожчало!
Аналітикиня Українського клубу аграрного бізнесу Світлана Литвин зазначає, що основний фактор подорожчання овочів в Україні -
заблоковані аграрні підприємства в Херсонській і Запорізькій областях.
Адже саме в цих регіонах було найбільше аграрних компаній, які вирощували продукцію для всієї країни.
Знизилася пропозиція - збільшилася ціна на овочі.
Найбільш у цьому плані постраждають такі овочі як томати, цибуля, перець.
Тому що частка промислового виробництва (я тут називаю фермерські господарства, підприємства,
які ціленаправлено вирощують свою продукцію для подальшої реалізації) частка якраз відчутна.
Наприклад, цибулі - це 37%. Моркви 29%. Томатів - 33%.
Відповідно, ми не маємо зараз можливості отримати овочі, вирощені минулого року, з таких територій.
І саме за рахунок цього у нас на всій території України відчутно зростає ціна.
Наприклад, херсонські томати продавці замінюють на ті, які вирощують в Умані й Київській області,
а також розраховують на імпорт з Туреччини. Картопля тепер з Миколаївської області.
Змінилися і логістичні ланцюжки. Чимало доріг тепер зруйновано, а порти заблоковані, що унеможливлює імпорт з Туреччини морем.
Це також впливає на ціну товарів.
Водночас торговці зауважують, що через зростання курсу іноземної валюти, збільшуються ціни й на доповнюючі продукти,
необхідні для вирощування городини.
Олександр Дронов на ярмарку продає виключно продукцію, яку сам вирощує в Київській області.
Чоловік каже, що поки не піднімає ціни на свої овочі й зелень, тому, в першу чергу, страждає його кишеня.
Подорожчало дуже сильно насіння. Стало дефіцитним, тому що ми закуповували виключно голландське насіння.
Були й польські, але 80% було голландське. Воно подорожчало сильно за рахунок курсу євро,
по-друге, їхня доставка, і по-третє, мало хто возить - ви ж розумієте, всі йдуть на фронт. Багато людей, а жінки не можуть возить.
Подекуди аграрні підприємства потерпають через безпосередні наслідки бойових дій. І не лише на півдні та сході України.
Це аграрне підприємство вирощує органічні овочі. З теплиць Житомирщини, вони постачають свою продукцію переважно
до супермаркетів Києва, але й інших великих міст. Собівартість продукції цієї компанії зросла ще і тому,
що склади з органічними добривами, якими компанія користувалася, розмбомбили.
Однак щойно компанія налагодили постачання добрив з Європи, вони відновили процес вирощування овочів.
Олександр Барбарук - керівник операційних процесів компанії.
За його словами, компанія не буде поступатися принципами екологічного виробництва, щоб зменшити собівартість.
Ми бачимо, що це земля. Тут ми використовуємо добрива, але органічні. Вона виглядає як земля, пахне як земля, і досить родюча.
У теплицях компанії цілорічно вирощують практично всі види овочів.
Чимало коштів йде на енергоносії, оскільки компанія не тільки освітлюється, але й опалюється виключно за рахунок електропристроїв.
Логістика теж подорожчала, нарікає виконавчий директор агрокомпанії.
Попри це, обсяги виробництва не зменшуватимуть, навпаки - планують розбудовувати компанію.
Адже попит супермаркетів на альтернативи овочам з окупованих територій тільки збільшується.
Щоправда, платоспроможних покупців від початку війни поменшало.
Зі столиці виїхала велика кількість людей. Мільйони виїхали взагалі з України.
І тому, за рахунок людей, які виїхали за кордон, а ми розуміємо, що це не самі бідні верстви населення.
А покупець наш - це середній клас і, може, й вище, ну, очевидно, що зменшилася кількість.
Водночас експерти не виключають, що саме зменшення попиту може припинити зростання цін.
Подальше зростання цін буде обмежуватися купівельною спроможністю.
Коли ціна стане настільки некомфортною, що люди замість трьох кілограмів, будуть купувати пів кілограма, щоб зварити борщ не двічі на тиждень,
а раз в місяць. Відповідно, буде зменшуватися попит, тому буде зменшуватися ціна на полицях.
Тому що виробникам також потрібно реалізувати цю продукцію.
За словами експертки, варто очікувати ще максимум 10-15% зростання, допоки ціни на овочі досягнуть свого піку.
Продавці з київського ярмарку також помітили зменшення попиту.
Так, раніше у мене, кілограм-два огірка, помідорів брали, а сьогодні - аби поїсти і на завтра.
Люди це відчувають. Бо зарплати не піднялися, пенсії не піднялися.
Платоспроможність мала в людей, зарплати, пенсії, самі розумієте - немає.
Так що раніше могли брати по кілограму, тепер по пів кіло грама, 300 грам беруть, як коли.
Тим часом, поки одні містяни чекають зниження цін, інші вирішують брати ситуацію в свої руки.
Що стосується квітів, м'ята, чебрець, календула, чорнобривці.
Ми обрали ті квіти, які є їстівними, які можна використовувати на кухні.
З чорнобривців роблять прекрасне песто, аджику, є оригінальні грузинські рецепти.
Календула можна прекрасно і коктейлі фарбувати, і в чай її можна додавати.
Ці чаї продаються за шалені гроші. Крокуси їстівні, ті, що шафранні, у нас були з минулого року, їх подарувала моя мама.
Цегла замість дренажу, комод замість ящиків для розсади.
В одному з кафе у центрі Києва на місці зруйнованих гаражів з'явилися грядки з буряком, томатами, перцями та їстівними квітами.
Співзасновниця проєкту "СквотГород" каже, що мала дві мети.
Частково здешевити виробництво страв і коктейлів в барі, але також - показати приклад містянам, як можна самостійно забезпечувати себе овочами.
На прикладі коктейлю джин-гарден. Це популярний літній коктейль, ми його завжди робили. Цього року, коли ми почали підраховувати його собівартість.
Минулого року собівартість огірків була від 80 до 110 грн кілограм, навіть не в сезон.
Цієї весни огірки коштували 150 грн кілограм, зараз навіть в оптовій закупці 120, і навряд чи вони будуть дешевшими,
тому що ми знаємо, що сталося і з теплицями в області, і з можливостями їхнього обслуговування, і з логістикою, і з цінами на бензин.
Аби своїм експериментом надихати та заохочувати інших, співзасновниці "СквотГороду" створили інструкції:
як з мінімальними витратами висадити грядки навіть у себе на балконі.
Водночас сама Тамара Бабакова брала за приклад історичний кейс - "Сади перемоги".
Сам британський проєкт "Сади перемоги", так само, ви знаєте, після Другої світової в Тіргартені в Берліні, люди мали городи й вирощували їх.
І це така популярна підчасвоєнна, і що важливо, антивоєнна штука. Бо коли ти вирощуєш там, де була руїна - будувати довго.
Вирощувати дерева - довго і дорого. І це вимагає сезонності, планування, бюджету.
Виростити врожай - на будь-якому балконі, дворі, пустирі, на парковці, як ми це робимо, можна протягом 2-3 місяців.
А зараз важко планувати на довший термін.
Ще одна українська ініціатива під назвою "Сади перемоги" також допомогає громадам навчитися самозабезпеченню в продовольстві.
На сайті проєкту можна знайти інструкції, як висадити город для громади, а також прорахувати, скільки і чого потрібно для конкретної кількості людей.
У рамках ініціативи люди також можуть отримати консультації щодо висадки городини.
За словами очільниці "Садів перемоги", до них звернулися вже понад 200 громад.
Тож допоки Росія продовжуватиме блокувати українські порти, а також окуповувати південні українські області,
усі, хто не хоче чи не може платити за овочі вдвічі більше, можуть надихатися прикладами Другої світової війни.